nous avons décidé de consacrer notre
première audition en réunion plinière
depuis le dernier renouvellement
sénatorial à Édouard Duran magistrat
plus précisément juge des enfants il est
un interlocuteur privilégié et fidèle de
notre délégation depuis de nombreuses
années nous l'avons entendu sur tous les
sujets concernant les violences faites
aux femmes les violences faites aux
enfants et la protection de l'enfance
depuis plus de 2 ans maintenant il est
le président avec Nathalie Mathieu de la
commission indépendante sur l'inceste et
les violences sexuelles faites aux
enfants plus connu sous le nom de
CIVIS cette commission a été installée
le 11 mars 2021 cher Édouard Duran nous
nous sommes rencontrés au cours des
travaux de la mission d'information du
Sénat sur les violences sexuelles sur
mineurs en institution dont j'étais
corrapporteur au côté de Marie Mercier
notamment qui maintenant a rejoint la
délégation aux droits des femmes et à
l'égalité des chances entre les hommes
et les femmes à l'époque nous avions
volontairement décidé de ne pas traiter
des cas d'inceste notre mission
concernait en effet les infractions
sexuelles susceptibles d'être commises
par des personnes en contact avec des
mineurs dans le cadre de l'exercice de
leur métier ou de leur fonction or nous
le savons la majorité des violences
sexuelles sur mineurs sont commises dans
le cercle familial l'installation en
2021 de la civise était donc bienvenue
l'objectif était double d'abord mieux
connaître et faire connaître l'ampleur
des violences sexuelles faites aux
enfants ensuite formuler des
recommandations pour mieux prévenir les
violences sexuelles mieux protéger les
enfants et lutter contre l'impunité des
agresseurs pour se faire la priorité
était de recueillir des témoignages de
victimes le travail que vous avez mené
est de ce point de vue
titanesque et
salvateur le Tour de France de la civise
a été libérateur pour beaucoup de
victimes une main tendue qui permet de
déposer son fardeau comme le soulignait
l'un de vos nombreux témoins nous savons
d'ailleurs qu'il y a encore une grande
attente de la part des victimes après
avoir reçu plus de 11000 témoignag la
civise avait rendu au mois de mars 2022
des conclusions intermédiaires et
formulé 20
préconisations son rapport final et ses
préconisations après 3 années de travail
sont rendu publ seront rendus public le
20 novembre
prochain nous n'attendons bien
évidemment pas de vous que vous nous
dévoiliez en avant-premières les
conclusions de ce
rapport mais que vous nous dressiez un
bilan de ces tro années et que vous
indiquiez les raisons pour lesquelles
vous pensez aujourd'hui qu'il est
important de poursuivre le
travail dans le cadre de cette
commission cher Édouard Duran je vous
laisse sans plus tarder la parole mais
pour autant j'ai quand même je vais déjà
a formulé une petite question issue de
débat que nous venons d'avoir dans votre
présentation pourrez-vous nous dire qui
quel est le ministère qui vous finance
quel est le budget parce que c'est le
moment où nous pouvons agir sur le
budget et donc une question a été posée
ce serait bien de de façon pratique de
nous en donner cette réponse donc cette
question ajoutée je vous laisse sans
plus tarder la parole nous pourrons
ensuite engager avec l'ensemble des
membres de la délégation ici présent un
échange euh je rappelle à toute fins
utile que cette audition fait l'objet
d'une captation audiovisuelle et qu'elle
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat cher Édouard Durand à
vous madame la Présidente Mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur le
sénateur je suis honoré évidemment et la
civise est honorée que vous lui
consacriez cette première audition
plainère
l'ouverture de vos travaux de la
délégation après son renouvellement et
je suis d'autant plus confus d'arriver
en retard ayant pensé que vous
m'attendiez à 9h30 et non à 9h veuillez
m'excuser je suis absolument navré de ce
retard c'est un grand honneur
et un grand réconfort madame la
Présidente que vous et vos collègues
ayez pensé qu'il était utile de débuter
vos travaux avec quelques mots de la CIV
sur les enfants violés et pendant le
temps que nous aurons consacré à cet
échange 20 30 enfants auront été violés
et agressés
sexuellement car toutes les 3
minutes un enfant est victime de
violence
sexuelle merci donc du temps que vous
consacrez à la
civise j'espère que en 2024 et en 2025
vous aurez
l'opportunité de recevoir encore les
femmes et les hommes qui en seront
membres si elle n'a pas disparu
permettez-moi avant de d'entrer vraiment
dans mon
propos de dire à quel
point je suis heureux de rester fidèle à
la délégation droits des femmes du
Sénat pour tous les travaux que vous
menez depuis si longtemps et
permettez-moi aussi de
de dire le plaisir de vous voir à cette
place de présidente permettez-moi enfin
de saluer très
chaleureusement madame la sénatrice
Annique billon aujourd'hui
vice-présidente de la délégation qui l'a
présidé pendant longtemps et avec
beaucoup d'énergie et d'engagement comme
vous le faites aujourd'hui cher anque je
vous redis toute mon amitié et ma
fidélité le 23 janvier 2021 le président
président de la République a pris la
parole publiquement et s'est adressé à
tous les hommes à toutes les femmes qui
avaient été victimes de viol et
d'agression sexuelle dans leur enfance
d'inceste
particulièrement et il leur a
dit on vous croit et vous ne serez plus
jamais seul et c'est en prononçant ces
mots qu'il a désigné Nathalie Mathieu et
moi-même pour piloter ce que nous
appellerions plus tard la commission
indépendante sur l'inceste et les
violences sexuelles faites aux
enfants dans un moment social assez
particulier dont vous vous souvenez très
bien qui est la publication par Camille
couchner du livre la famille AG grande
il faut que des voix autorisées
s'élèvent de temps en
temps pour que nous voulions bien
accorder un peu d'attention aux enfants
invisibles 160000 enfants chaque année
sont victimes de violence sexuelle dans
notre pays mais ces enfants ne sont pas
dans les
tribunaux ils ne sont pas dans les
hôpitaux ils ne sont pas dans les
services sociaux ils y sont
naturellement mais nous ne reconnaissons
pas qu'ils sont des enfants victimes de
violence sexuelle ces voies autorisées
comme au début du mois de septembre
Emmanuel Bard comme Eva Thomas comme
Christine Ango et d'autres permettent
que de temps en temps la société les
pouvoirs publics accordent un peu
d'attention aux violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants aux enfants victimes
et aux
agresseurs il s'agit d'une d'une
réalité si terrifiante que nous
préférons ne pas la prendre en compte ne
pas la
voir des recherches
scientifiques montre que les agresseurs
les pédocriminels
peuvent faire jusqu'à 150 victimes
enfants dans leur carrière
d'agresseur les pédocriminels qui
agressent préférentiellement des garçons
peuvent faire jusqu'à 150 victimes les
pédocriminels qui agressent
préférentiellement des filles peuvent
faire jusqu'à 60 80
victimes et lorsque le pédocriminel n'a
pas une multitude
d'enfants dont il peut prendre position
mais un enfant dans le cadre Clos de la
maison familiale alors il peut commettre
jusqu'à
2000 3000
violes nous avons reçu ces témoignage et
j'ai à l'oreille les paroles de ces
hommes et de ces femmes qui
disent un viol tous les
matins après le petit- dééjeuner avant
d'aller à
l'école si je
compte ça fait 3000
viols
si je compare à la réparation que j'ai
obtenue ça fait 30 € le
viol
nous vivons dans ce monde
là et je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur le fait
que nous avons toujours tendance
à
oublier que dans la
violence il y a de la
violence que ce mot n'est pas seulement
une
idée que la
réalité est de
l'ordre de la
destruction
physique de la
personne du petit bébé qui revient de la
maternité des adolescentes et des
adolescents qui rentrent à la
maison un témoin de l'assivisme disait
qu'après chaque viol son beau-père lui
brûlait la langue avec une
cigarette comment mieux
[Musique]
dire tu ne dois pas en
parler lorsque nous sommes allés à fort-
de-
France une personne en réunion publique
a témoigné en
disant qu'elle ne connaissait pas son
père et
que à l'âge de 8 ans 10
ans elle a été reconnue par son
père et que ça a été une grande joie de
sa
vie moi aussi j'ai un père et qu'elle
était
heureuse et qu'elle est partie en
vacances avec son père pendant 2
semaines et qu' l' emmené dans une
maison
isolée dans la nature une maison vide et
abandonné qu'il l' a laissé seul pendant
de semaines et qu'il venait chaque jour
lui apporter de l'eau et du pain et un
viol et ces
enfants continuent de
vivre ils deviennent des
adultes
parfois ces adultes ne peuvent pas
sortir de chez
eux lorsque nous avons fait la réunion
publique à Lille en janvier
2021 il y avait une dame qu'à la civise
nous appelons la dame en rose parce
qu'elle avait un grand mteau
rose et qui a pris la parole en disant
c'est la première fois depuis plusieurs
années que je sors de chez
moi et j'ai fais plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres accompagné de ma
fille et je suis sorti pour venir
témoigner à la
civise
d'autres peuvent sortir de chez elle ou
de chez eux et vont
travailler et un homme m'a dit en
audition
individuelle mon patron a le même parfum
que mon
agresseur à chaque fois que je suis avec
mon
patron je revis les viols et ceci
s'appelle les revivissances
traumatiques mais je ne peux pas dire à
mon patron qu'il doit changer de
parfum peut-être que je dois arrêter de
travailler évidemment ces personnes
auront la retraite que vous
imaginez les soins leur coûtent des
dizaines de milliers
d'euros alors que ce sont des soins qui
ne peuvent pas les soigner puisque la
plupart du temps ce ne sont pas des
soins spécialisés du
psychotraumatisme le coût social pour la
société toute entière est de
9,7 milliards d'euros par an nous
l'avons démontré dans la vie que nous
avons publié le 12 juin 2023 le coût du
dénis
9,7 milliards
d'euros séparé le coût pour les dépenses
publiques essentiellement pour l'État et
la sécurité sociale un/ers pour les
dépenses immédiates de santé de police
de justice 2 tiers pour les conséquences
à long terme et ces conséquences à long
terme ce sont les
conséquences individuell et
social des conséquences sur la santé
pour les victimes ce que Jean-Marc
Sauvet vice-président horaire du Conseil
d'État et qui fut président de la
commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans
l'égise appelé à juste titre
l'empêchement d'être ce que la civise
appelle le présent perpétuel de la
souffrance alors ayant dit que
l'impunité
des violeurs d'enfants coûte près de 10
milliards par d'euros par an à la aux
dépenses publiques de l'État je peux
dire que le budget qui a été donné à la
civise est de 4 millions pour les de
années initiales de son mandat et c'est
un effort qui est un effort réel la
civise n'a jamais été institué pour
àelle seul et par elle
seul régler la totalité des problèmes
contenus dans le vocable violence
sexuelle faite aux
enfants pendant 3 ans les 3 ans qui
iront jusqu'au 31 décembre 2023 nous
n'aurons pas épuisé la totalité du
budget qui nous aura été confié parce
que la civise est une institution
responsable et
économe que nous aurons
dépensé près de la moitié du budget qui
qui nous est alloué moins
même veuillez m'excuser d'être euh
encore assez imprécis sur le le fléchage
des des dépenses nous sommes sous la
tutelle euh du ministère des ministères
sociaux puisque l'initiative de cette
commission revient au mérite d'Adrien
taquet secrétaire d'État euh à l'enfance
et aux familles euh en août 2020 puis en
janvier 2021 euh nous sommes rattachés à
la direction générale de la cohésion
sociale et euh au secrétariat général
des ministères
sociaux à ce jour nous avons recueilli
près de 30000
témoignages il y a dans ce pays 5,5
millions de femmes et d'hommes adultes
qui ont été victimes de violence
sexuelle dans leur enfant et notamment
d'inceste une personne sur
10 30000
témoignages dans des réunions publiques
exceptionnelles d'intensité et de
dignité
dans les auditions individuelles par
téléphone par mail et sur notre
questionnaire en ligne et des personnes
nous
disent quelques semaines après leur
audition j'ai obtenu la réparation que
j'ai attendu toute ma vie
et un jour le 21 juin dernier d'ailleurs
précisément c'était la fête de la
musique je rentrer chez moi à Paris le
soir et je suis euh je je croise un
couple un homme et une femme qui
m'interpelle j'étais au téléphone avec
une collègue membre de la
civise et le monsieur me
dit 60 70 ans il me dit j'étais
auditionné par une de vos collègues il y
a pas
longtemps et il me il me raconte et je
comprends en l'écoutant que il a été
auditionné par la collègue avec qui
j'étais en train de parler au
téléphone je lui dis mais je je suis
avec elle il m'attrape le bras il me dit
dites-lui qu'elle a changé ma
vie voilà ce que fait la f civise
évidemment c'est une mission qui nous
dépasse totalement nous
l'ignorions mais voilà ce que fait la
civise en votre nom en notre nom à
tous restituer la
légitimité des
enfants anéanti par la
violence je voudrais dire deux ou trois
autres choses si vous me le permettez
nous avons montré dans notre avis du 21
septembre
2023 ce que vous savez déjà la violence
sexuelle
est un anéantissement de
l'être une négation la violence est
toujours une négation de l'être
et une négation
de la légitimité du
langage même quand elle passe par le
sexe la violence dis toujours tu
m'appartiens pour sortir du néant il
faut un
tiers qui disent la loi interdit la
violence un ti qui dis je te crois je te
protège
dans cet avis du 21 septembre 2023 nous
avons
montré que
8 % des enfants victimes de violence
sexuelle c'est-à-dire presque
aucun lorsqu'il révèle les violences
sexuelles obtiennent cette réponse je te
crois je te
protège cette réponse qui s'appelle un
soutien social
positif dans 92 % des
cas la réponse est de l'ordre du soutien
social négatif ou de l'absence de
soutien le soutien social négatif c'est
je te
crois et le
néant
rien
lorsque l'enfant révèle des violences à
un
professionnel dans 60 % des
cas le professionnel ne fait
rien l'absence de soutien social c'est
tuent une victime nous
disait lorsque je suis sorti de la
chambre de mon grand-père j'ai dit à ma
grand-père à ma grand-mère ce qu'il me
faisait elle m'a donné une paire de gifl
elle m'a dit tu ne fais plus partie de
cette
famille alors évidemment nous nous ne
ferions pas comme ça mais il a doit y
avoir des gens qui le font puisque
presque tous les
enfants se heurte à un second
anéantissement
on dit qu'un juge ne devrait pas
[Musique]
dire il faut dire aux victimes de
violence je te
crois pourtant la raison le
commande la raison même le
commande tout autre attitude est
contraire à la raison le risque que nous
courons n'est pas d'inventer des
victimes il est de laisser passer sous
nos yeux au tribunal à l'hôpital au
Sénat et ailleurs des enfants victimes
sans les
protéger il est de dépenser chaque année
milliards
pourquoi parce que nous avons des
principes nous disons aux enfants
victimes nous voudrions bien te protéger
mais nous avons des
principes la
neutralité primou non
noséré la présomption
d'innocence je suis juge qui ici dans
cette
salle porterait atteinte au principe de
la présomption
d'innocence moins que moi personne il
structure mon être même de
magistrat mais il ne faut pas mal
l'interpréter
si 3
% des mises en cause pour viol sur
mineur sont
condamnés c'est que nous vivons dans un
système
d'impunité pourquoi maintenir la
civise premièrement parce que
l'affaire dont j'ai parlé le livre dont
j'ai parlé qui a donné lieu la civise et
bien il y en aura une autre dans
quelques jours dans quelques semaines
dans quelques
mois dira-t-on nous allons créer une
commission elle
existe pourquoi maintenir la
civise parce qu'elle répond à un
besoin un besoin individuel pour chaque
personne et un besoin
social 30000 témoignages c'est un
mouvement
social c'estex
expérience d'un
collectif pourquoi maintenir la CIVIS
parce que les 160000 enfants victimes
chaque année ce ne sont pas 160000
affaires privées c'est un problème
d'ordre
publque un problème de santé
publique pourquoi maintenir la
civise parce que
comme le dit Charles
pegy le plus difficile c'est de voir ce
que l'on
voit parce qu'il est beaucoup plus
commode de faire comme si les enfants
mentaient comme si les mères
manipulaient les
enfants comme si les médecins vous la
simissez abusivement dans l'intimité des
familles moi j'ai accompagné un médecin
devant une chambre
disciplinaire et j'avais
honte honte d'appartenir à un groupe
humain qui envoie des injonctions
paradoxal vous pouvez nous faire
confiance chers petits enfants
dites-nous si vous êtes victime de
violence
sexuelle mais nous ne vous croirons
pas et vous les mères vous devez
protéger vos
enfants c'est l'étymologie même de ce
mot qui vous
désigne la
confiance mais si vous révélez les
violences que vous révèle votre enfant
nous vous dirons que vous êtes
aliénante vous avez sans doute vu cette
vidéo du docteur Gerner ce psychiatre
qui a inventé le concept d'aliénation
parentale il le dit
devant le monde entier comme témoin si
un enfant dit à sa mère papa me viole la
mère doit gifler son enfant et lui dire
ne parle pas comme ça de ton
père si elle va au commissariat au
tribunal ou ailleur il faut la mettre en
prison alors je vous dis cette jeune
fille sort de la chambre de son
grand-père elle dit à sa grand-mère
voilà ce que fait mon grand-père la
grand-mère gifle sa petite fille et lui
dit tu ne fais plus partie de cette
famille vous êtes
choqué mais
si vous recevez à ma
place quelqu'un qui vous
dira je pense que le docteur Gartner a
bien fait d'inventer le concept
d'aliénation parentale car les mères
mentent et qu'il avait raison de
dire si un enfant sort de la chambre de
son grand-père et dit à sa grand-mère je
pas voilà ce que me fait grand-père
cette grand-mère a raison de gifler sa
petite fille et de lui dire je ne veux
pas que tu parles comme ça de ton
grand-père il faut
choisir Charles pegy encore dit le monde
sera jugé sur ce qu'il aa considéré
comme négociable ou non
négociable toute la question est
là et en effet toute la question est là
qui voulons-nous
protéger si ce sont les
enfants alors faisons en sorte que cela
se voit plus clairement car ce n'est pas
une question de prise de conscience
individuelle la prise de conscience a eu
lieu c'est une question de politique
publique le repérage des enfants
victimes le traitement i la réparation
incluant le soin et la
prévention primaire secondaire tertière
etquatnaire une politique
publique de quel côté de la frontière
sommes-nous je vous remercie de votre
attention merci beaucoup c'est difficile
de reprendre la parole après ouais un
tel exposé
euh donc avant de donner la parole au
collègues qui l'ont déjà demandé et je
propose aux autres de se signaler si euh
elles souhait poser il ou ell souhait
poser des questions euh ma première
question ce sera euh alors ma
première remarque je dirais question
c'est quand vous dites que une absence
de réponse c'est dire tu mens n'est-ce
pas aussi dire mais c'est normal en fait
vu comment les choses sont banalisées
oui madame la Présidente vous avez
absolument raison je vous remercie de de
de formuler la question de de cette
manière aussi clairement qu'est-ce que
le déni
et euh votre question pose la question
du problème du déniis qu'est-ce que le
dénis le déniis c'est ça n'existe
pas ça n'est pas
vrai ça n'est pas
grave ça ne nous regarde
pas ça n'a pas de
conséquence ce n'est pas si
fréquent c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
société a évolué et que nous ne disons
pas ça n'est pas vrai ça n'existe pas
nous disons c'est vrai ça
existe nous avons une
idée plus ou moins confuse mais une
idée de ce que représente 5,5 millions
de
victimes nous avons une idée de ce que
veut dire 160000 enfants victimes chaque
année et nous avons lorsque je vous ai
dit ces témoignage pardon de l'avoir
fait mais ils disent ce qu'est la
réalité et quand quand je suis certain
quand j'ai prononcé ces mots vous avez
eu une image dans la tête de ce que ces
mots veulent dire ce n'est pas pour rien
que Christine Ango dit au sujet de son
œuvre je veux que les mots soient
visibles
mais
l'idée s frite devant chaque enfant
réel l'idée générale disparaît ne tient
plus devant chaque enfant
réel pour la raison que vous venez de
dire madame la Présidente qui est la
raison
fondamentale dis mais ce n'est pas si
grave nous disons au contraire mais
repérer les violences poser la question
des violences aux enfants c'est encore
pire que les violences
elles-mêmes parce que ça va les
traumatiser alors que c'est un
déterminant majeur de santé à lâge
adulte et nous ne posons pas la question
des violences donc nous soignons autre
chose
que ce qui cause la
souffrance et
oui ce que vous dites est crucial madame
la
Présidente purement pratique le budget
quel
ministère notre budget
est pour notre budget de de
fonctionnement 4 million d'euros
sur le budget des ministères sociaux la
direction générale de la cohésion
sociale pour les dépenses concernant
l'action de la
civise par exemple la recherche experte
que nous avons mené sur le chiffrage du
coût annuel des violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants et bien a été confié
à des experts et sur le budget de la
civise dans le budget de la DGCS nos
dépenses d'organisation de
fonctionnement aller faire une réunion
publique à fort-de-fance ou à la Réunion
ou à Toulouse c'est le secrétariat
général des ministères sociaux et
l'équipe permanente de la civise les
coprésident le secrétaire général les
rapporteurs tous les les emplois de
l'équipe
permanente ont une prise en charge avec
un caractère un peu interministériel
contenu de l'objet même de la mission de
la civise la plupart des emplois sont
assumés par les ministères sociaux
certains le sont par le ministère de la
Justice ministère de l'Intérieur
ministère de l'Éducation
nationale
c'est je voudrais je me permets de dire
à ce sujet
que la
civise n'occupe l'espace
institutionnel d'aucune autre
institution
elle ne double pas
elle ne copie pas un schéma
institutionnel ou des missions
institutionnelles déjà rempli par
ailleurs
elle occupe un espace institutionnel un
peu inédit mais légitime pour une
mission
inédite qu'aucune autre institution n'a
rempli jusqu'à ce jour et il serait
surprenant que cela
change je vais maintenant donner la
parole aux collègues qui l'ont demandé
par ordre Marie-Pierre Monier Lord Arcos
Annique billon Colomb Rossel et Marc
lamen donc Marie-Pierre Monier merci
madame la Présidente oui c'est très dur
je reprends vos mots cher président de
prendre la parole après vous monsieur le
juge merci merci à la délégation d'avoir
organisé cette audition vraiment et
bravo bravo pour ce que vous
faites à travers vos propos c'est
au-delà de l'émotion c'est une
reconnaissance de violence fait aux
enfants qui n'est pas faite dans notre
monde vous avez dit nous avons un
engagement politique à prendre pour que
cela soit reconnu et que des
préconisations qui j'ai bien compris
arriveront après soit prises
et je m'engage pour mon couple mais je
pense que nous nous serons nombreux et
nombreuses ici à soutenir votre action
et à porter votre voix et la voix de ces
enfants qui sont victimes au sein du
Sénat donc j'ai bien compris dans V
propos que vous demandez le maintien de
de la civise et sachez que vous avez mon
soutien et notre
soutien globalement et on verra si on
peut à l'occasion du PLFSS ou PLF si on
peut aussi voir le côté financier de la
chose en septembre votre collègue
co-présidente Nathalie Mathieu est
intervenue en Dr dans mon département et
lors d'un colloque sur l'inceste
organisé par l'association Crisalis et
qui
rassemble des administrateurs adoc et à
cette occasion les acteurs les actrices
de terrain présents sont ont unanimement
affirmé combien le travail du CIVIS est
précieux et je suis convaincue que nous
devons être toutes et tous à vos côtés
pour que votre action s'inscrive
vraiment dans la durée ce premier
rapport est un choc
un travail dans la durée permettra
vraiment de transformer ce choc en force
motrice pour faire évoluer la société et
la loi et ainsi faire reculer les vience
concrète et vos derniers propos le
montrent comme quoi il ne faut pas
s'arrêter comme quoi il n'y a aucune
autre institution qui fait ce travail
que vous avez fait d'écoutes et au-delà
du travail d'écoutes il faut des
préconisations donc vraiment vous avez
déjà commencé à parler mais dites-nous
comment on peut nous en tant que
parlementaire au mieux agir à vos côtés
si vous avez déjà des des pistes
peut-être que ça déflorera les
recommandations que vous avez faire mais
voilà ensuite dans vos conclusions
intermédiaire vous préconisez de rendre
effectives les séances d'éducation à la
vie sexuelle et affective alors au sein
de l'allégation nous sommes mobilisés
sur ce sujet et
sur le manque d'Efficient il n'y a pas
en fait il y en a très peu je crois que
c'est 15 % lycé école et 20 % collège
d'heur qui sont effectués pour votre
information nous avons un ébillon qui
était président donc de la délégation
droit des femmes hier et moi-même
interpellé le ministre deéducation àal
sur ce sujet et nous avons été pour le
moins déçu et en fait inquiète de son
positionnement sur ce sujet donc
j'aimerais bien que vous confirmiez il y
a eu peu d'avance concrte quel est votre
avis et l'intérêt de de ces 3 heures et
puis plus largement au sein du milieu
scolaire que préconiseriez-vous pour
rendre cet environnement plus à même de
détecter les situations de violence et
répondre de façon efficace
merci Lord Arcos merci merci madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur le Juge et
toujours avec beaucoup d'émotion qu'on
vous entend en effet comme vient de le
dire Marie-Pierre Monier et merci pour
votre action et on sera à vos côtés je
vais rebondir tout de suite sur ce que
vient de dire Marie-Pierre justement je
voulais aussi vous parler du milieu
scolaire je vais prendre deux exemple
mais concernant le milieu scolaire un
exemple
précis on se rend compte quand même en
effet nos encadrants scolaires ont du
mal encore à à voir l'urgence de de de
répondre j'ai une école dans le sud des
sones et un petit garçon en CP depuis
début de l'année fait des fation à ces
petits camarades à 5
ans le la direction ne voit que l'aspect
harcèlement en fait vis-à-vis des de ses
victimes
moi ma réaction quand une élu m'en a
parlé c'était tout de suite de dire ce
petit garçon de 5 ans ne peut pas faire
des fellations si lui-même ne subit pas
des violences et sûrement dans le milieu
familial donc on se rend compte quand
même qu'il y a une sensibilisation
encore à à trouver à
faire dès le plus jeune âge à l'école et
on en parlait avant que vous arriviez on
en a parlé à au ministre Atal bien
évidemment on peut pas parler de
sexualité tout le long de de de son
cursus scolaire de la même façon en
étant adolescent que que petit et donc
elle a 5 ans ben c'est le respect du
corps mais voyez enfin là je je trouve
qu'il y a un décalage complet
entre voilà cette inquiétude énorme et
autre cas alors je sors du milieu
scolaire qui m'inquiète aussi beaucoup
c'est et vous en avez souvent parlé
monsieur le juge en cas de séparation
pour violence conjugale violence
physique et et souvent viol
euh quand on continue à avoir la garde
alors je je je mets des bémoles parce
que moi j'étais souvent sollicité par
des papas qui souhaiteraient qu'on
puisse continuer à proposer à la garde
alterné et aujourd'hui on caricature
souvent des séparations qui se sont mal
passées en disant Marie violent donc
forcément père violent donc je je je
là-dessus on a peut-être une petite
différence mais c'est vrai que j'
toujours de faire la différence mais et
j'ai le cas euh d'une maman qui me dit
voilà ma ma fille de 10 ans euh devait
continuer à aller voir son père tous les
tous les 15 jours euh bien évidemment
depuis 6 mois elle ne veut plus elle ne
parle pas je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
et cetera et bien le procureur
euh a souhaité en fait la placer à la
œuf et en fait moi quand je suis
retournée parce que je suis aussi
conseillère départemental auprès de des
services concernés dans mon département
il me disent oui malheureusement la
justice souvent par facilité en cas de
conflit entre les deux parents parce
qu'ils ne savent pas si en effet la mère
n'est pas en train de remonter les
enfants contre le père
et
finalement lui fasse porter le le le
conflit ben le mieux c'est finalement
sortir extraire l'enfant du milieu
familial parce que finalement on tranche
pas entre les
deux c'est abérrant parce qu'en fait la
mère c'est double peine en fait elle
alerte sur le fait qu'elle a peut-être
d'abord déjà elle-même est victime et et
elle voit que sa fille est en danger et
donc on va lui retirer la garde de son
enfant et du coup je suis retourné vers
cette mère en disant essayez de
continuer
euh d'être dans la la médiation avec
votre ex mari parce que sinon vous
risquez en effet si vous allez plus loin
avec services sociaux qu'on vous retire
votre la garde de votre
enfant
Annique billon merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Président
cher Édouard d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de notre présidente et de
la délégation aux droits des femmes
puisque il y a la délégation a été assez
renouvelé et et je pense que c'est la
première fois aussi que certains de nos
collègues vous entendent et pour nous
qui sommes habitués c'est toujours un
avec beaucoup
d'attention de presque de d'un
recueillement qu'on vous écoute avec euh
beaucoup de aussi de d'inquiétude parce
que depuis ce toutes ces années où vous
travaer sur le sujet j'imagine que
lorsqu'on est confronté à ces
témoignages et bien on absorbe beaucoup
de douleur beaucoup et on les vit
soi-même physiquement et moralement donc
vous remercier aussi puisque vous avez
eu des mots très aimables à mon égard en
début d'intervention vous remercie aussi
puisque depuis 9 ans que je suis dans
cette délégation et depuis pendant 6 ans
à la présidence je je dois vous dire que
vos travaux et j'y associe Ernestine
Ronet euh ont nourrit euh mon engagement
ma détermination apporter des sujets et
ont été d'une aide précieuse je voudrais
bien entendu vous dire que sur la civise
euh je je je je on le disait juste avant
que vous narriviez euh que je évidemment
je ferai tout ce qui est en ma
possibilité avec la délégation pour
pouvoir maintenir cette structure parce
que c'est un un espace d'écoute comme il
n'y a jamais eu et comme nous avons
besoin je voudrais vous poser une
première question par rapport à cet
espace d'écoute c'est que euh vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure lors de sa
création la civise a été initié par le
ministre Adrien taquet estimez-vous euh
en fait c'est une question peut-être un
petit peu impertinente estimez-vous que
le changement de ministre et les
propositions que vous avez pu faire à la
fois en terme de d'autorité parentale à
la fois en terme de signalement dans vos
différents points d'étape euh est-ce que
vous estimez que ces positions de la
civise peuvent être à l'origine d'une
volonté puisque pour avoir eu des
échanges avec des ministère je sais que
certaines de vos propositions n'étaient
pas toutes portées au sein enfin accepté
ou partager au sein du gouvernement donc
c'est c'est c'est ma première question
euh ensuite il y a un argument quand
même vous avez eu le l'honnêteté de nous
dire qu'il y avait un budget de 4
million d'euros pour 2 ans donc ces 4
millions d'euros sont à moitié consommés
grosso modo vous n'êtes pas expert
comptable moi non plus donc on vous fait
grâce de la précision des des chiffres
euh mais donc à partir du moment je
pense que c'est un argument fort à
partir du moment où vous n'avez consommé
que la moitié sur 2 ans
approximativement on peut imaginer s'il
n'y a pas de de de blocage politique sur
la civise ça revient à ma question
précédente on peut imaginer qu'on peut
poursuivre la mission puisque les
crédits n'ont pas été totalement
consommés et que finalement là où on
avait imaginé 4 millions avec 2 millions
vous avez déjà fait un travail colossal
et nous en sommes tous persuadés autour
de la table donc signalement et puis
autorité parentale puisque notre
collègue l d' le le le citer un exemple
à l'instant euh où effectivement la
difficulté du signalement la difficulté
de de prendre des décisions lorsqu'on
est juge lorsqu'on est en en en
possibilité d'agir par rapport à cette
autorité parentale et par rapport à
l'image
magnifique on va dire assez romanesque
et poétique qu'on se fait tous de la
famille où ce serait le cocon qui
préserverait euh donc il y a cette image
qui sort dans les décisions
probablement vous dire pour finir euh
que moi je je je suis consciente
véritablement du travail qui a été fait
je regrette que vous n'ayez pas pu faire
plus mais vous pouvez pas physiquement
et et voilà parce que c'est toute cette
absorption de la douleur et quand même
physiquement et dans le temps donc qui
ait pas eu plus de de réunion et vous
dire que oui vous avez aidé vous avez
cité des des
témoignages ça a sauvé des des des vies
des vies d'adultes des vies d'enfants
des vies de famille et pour ma part je
suis en contact depuis de nombreux mois
avec une personne qui a eu la chance de
vous rencontrer euh et là on se rend
compte que cet espace d'écoute on l'a
pas cette ces ces qualités d'écoute on
ne l'a pas que ce soit à la justice ou
on l'a pas toujours je voudrais pas être
non plus caricatural on na pas des
personnes en capacité d'entendre
d'écouter d'agir et d'apporter les
bonnes réponses c'est pas donné à tout
le monde vous avez ces qualités donc
véritablement moi cette personne elle
savait que j'étais en contact avec vous
depuis de nombreux mois elle était venue
vers moi elle a eu la chance de vous
rencontrer c'est une bouée de sauvetage
de vous rencontrer la CIV je dis à
travers vous monsieur le Président toute
la civice pourquoi parce que trois
enfants une affaire évidemment sordide
un l'aîné avec un anus déchiré les
premiers témoignages de la la pédiatre
qui constate et qui fait un signalement
sauf que le premier expert qui voit
finalement son expertise est contredite
et là la question de cette femme c'est
de se demander comment elle va réussir à
protéger ses enfants dans la mesure où
les les les les décisions d'éloignement
ne ne peuvent plus être
finalement on revient dessus et elle se
dit est-ce que ma seule solution c'est
de partir à l'étranger avec mes enfants
et là on se dit comment est-ce possible
nous qui mettons tellement d'énergie
tellement d'argent à la fois dans la
justice parfois pas assez dans
l'éducation forcément et et lorsqu'on
parle pornographie elle aussi donc il y
a il y a plein de sujets sur lesquels on
doit mettre de on met de l'argent et
c'est c'est c'est pas efficace on doit
se poser les les questions pourquoi à un
moment balance cout bénéfice euh vous
avez dit presque 10
milliards d'euros euh quand va-t-on
prendre en compte le coût des violences
faites aux femmes le coût des violences
faites aux enfants la prévention coûtera
beaucoup moins cher que la réparation ou
que tenter d'accompagner ces victimes
qui nécessitent ce qui nécessite des
moyens colossaux donc voilà ces
questions et puis bien entendu je
rejoins la question de de ma collègue
Marie-Pierre comment peut-on vous aider
je sais que la présidente à à imaginé
vous soumettre un projet et je la
laisserai bien entendu vous en faire
part je vous remercie monsieur le
Président de la civise et plaisir de
vous retrouver ce matin merci à vous
pour tous votre travail et votre
engagement et votre
détermination je vous propose peut-être
de répondre déjà à ces trois euh
questions enfin ces trois
interpellations avec plusieurs questions
et ensuite donc nous aurons colombe
brossell
et Marie Mercier mais première
étape merci madames les sénatrices de
vos propos et et de vos questions très
importantes qui m'invite
à pour apporter des éléments de réponse
pour certaines questions différentes les
unes des
autres avoir un propos
liminire tous les ont été des
enfants et pourtant l'une l'une des
choses les plus
difficiles pour les
adulte c'est d'avoir de l'empathie pour
les
enfants de se
représenter ce que c'est que d'être un
enfant et nous appelons enfant un être
humain qui n'a pas encore 18
ans et nous avons
oublier alors que c'est la seule
expérience
universelle un
enfant
a ce que nous appelons des besoins
fondamentaux tous les
enfants les enfants qui naissent à Paris
les enfants qui naissent ailleurs en
France les enfants qui naissent ailleurs
sur la planète les enfants qui naissent
aujourd'hui les enfants qui qui sont nés
il y a 638
ans tous les enfants ont les mêmes
besoins
fondamentaux et le premier de tous ces
besoins est le besoin de
sécurité de sécurité évidemment la
violence et la violence sexuelle est la
négation de la totalité des besoins des
enfants cela va de soi le besoin de
sécurité c'est la sécurité physique et
psychique par la continuité
relationnelle et
affective avec une personne qui répond
au signes de détresse d'un
enfant je suis dans mon
perso j'ai
faim je
pleure je suis dans mon
berceau il y a un bruit dans la
rue qui me
réveille j'ai peur je
pleure
j'a mets un signe
d'appel pour répondre à une situation de
stress va-t-on répondre à
l'appel qui va répondre à l'appel et
comment de la façon
dont une ou de personnes répondent aux
appels de sécurité d'un
bébé c'est tout le rapport au monde qui
se construit pour la vie
entière qui va conduire à développer ce
que on appelle un attachement sécure
attachement
insécure et vous êtes je suis pas
psychologue ou
psychiatre pas faire une présentation de
l'attachement vous con connaiss aussi
bien sin mieux tout cela que
moi cela détermine non seulement le
bien-être de l'enfant dans l'enfance
mais son développement ce si
poser le droit de la famille est devenu
un champ de
ruine qui ne prend plus du tout en
compte le
réel
qu'est-ce que l'intérêt de
l'enfant madame la Présidente puis-je
vous
demander de de faire cet exercice avec
vos collègues que chacun dise pour sa
part ce qu'est l'intérêt de l'enfant et
nous aurons autant de réponses que de
personnes présentes dans cette salle
nous appelons intérêt de l'enfant ce que
nous estimons être bien nous
personnellement
et maintenant vous me connaissez un peu
donc vous imaginez ce que je pense être
l'intérêt de l'enfant mais l'intérêt de
l'enfant est aussi réel que cette
table et si je vous disais que ce sur
quoi je pose mes deux mains s'appelle
une
automobile vous me
diriez que je suis fatigué
ou que je ne vais pas bien et bien pour
les enfants nous faisons la même chose
nous prenons des
décisions qui n'ont aucun rapport avec
la réalité de la table avec l'intérêt de
l'enfant et moi mon grand rêve c'est que
le droit de la famille ne soit plus un
champ de ruine et cela est entre vos
mains c'est vrai pour
l'inceste
évidemment je ne mets pas les choses de
façon équivalente c'est vrai pour la
résidence
alternée il faut s'organiser en fonction
des besoins fondamentaux des enfants
c'est comme ça bien sûr que ça nous
limite oui ça nous
limite mais c'est comme ça qui voulons
nous
protéger
deuxiè élément
préalable il faut prendre en
compte ce que j'appelle les quatre
registres de la
parenté
or nous les humains nous avons tendance
à les confondre comme s'il ne faisait
qu'un ces quatre registre de la parenté
sont laffiliation l'autorité parentale
le lien et la rencontre
nous avons tendance à penser que dès
lors qu'il y a la filiation il faut
qu'il y ait l'autorité parentale le lien
et la rencontre mais ce sont quatre
registres
distincts on oblige des enfants à aller
en
prison voir leur père qui a tué leur
mère sous leurs yeux à coup de couteau
en disant mais c'est son père
on dit même elle a besoin de voir son
père
non un enfant a besoin de
dormir sans faire des cauchemars
traumatiques un enfant a besoin de
pouvoir faire des lignes d'écriture à
l'école la langue entre les
dents pour faire les boucles d'
l un enfant a besoin de
jouer sans être dans la répétition des
jeux
traumatiques un
enfant a
besoin d'apprendre et de
[Musique]
grandir et nous nous permettons aux
agresseurs de
à coloniser leur nuit et leur
jour parce
que nous pouvons tout concevoir nous
pouvons penser qu' il faut mettre des
êtres humains en
prison nous pouvons concevoir qu'il faut
mettre des êtres humains en prison avant
même qu'il ne soi
jugé mais toucher à l'autorité parentale
ça
non ça nous est insupport
alors ces enfants ne dorment
pas moi j'avais des je vois dans ma vie
de juge des enfants 20 ans dans les
tribunaux il a fallu que je
comprenne que je ne pouvais pas obliger
physiquement un enfant qu'on ne pouvait
pas le prendre par les bras le tirer de
la voiture pour le mettre dans une salle
visite médiatisé que c'était aussi
irréel que de dire que ceci s'appelle
une
automobile mais nous le faisons nous
disons il faut reconstruire le
lien il y a des raisons légitimes pour
qu'un enfant refuse de voir l'un de ses
parents et ces raisons sont
principalement
l'Alliance et le détachement
mais nous nous avons oublié qui nous
étions quand nous étions ha comme trois
pomes à
genou nous avons
oublié nos
émotions
d'enfant qu'est-ce que c'est l'alliance
et bien quand un enfant et même un AD à
ses parents qui se
séparent mais les enfants
souffrent même s'ils disent génial mes
parents
divorcent
et pour apaiser cette souffrance de la
séparation il est possible que les
enfants fassent alliance avec l'un de
leurs
parents je voudrais moins
souffrir je veux même à 15 ans hein je
veux
rester alors est-ce que les enfants
disent ça comme ça je veux rester avec
ma figure d'attachement
principale en
général les enfants disent avec ma mère
parce que c'est comme ça pour les
humains la figure d'attachement
principale le plus souvent c'est la mè
pas toujours mais le plus souvent c'est
comme ça c'est pas
grave c'est provisoire c'est
réversible est-ce qu'on peut comprendre
est-ce qu'on peut accepter l'idée qu'un
enfant dise je veux moins
souffrir je veux rester avec ma figure
de sécurité principale pourquoi est-ce
que ça nous heurte tant et l'autre
raison c'est le détachement j'ai
peur de celui qui me viole mais pourquoi
est-ce que c'est c'est difficile à
comprendre le placement moi je c'est ma
voyez c'est ma vie du juge des enfants
et puis c'est même précisément ma
dernière audience avant d'aller
rejoindre la
civise c'est une situation comme
ça les juges le décident et les services
éducatifs le demandent au juges il faut
mettre l'enfant en terrain
neutre il faut placer l'enfant en lieu
neutre moi je je m'entend dire au
service
éducatif il y a deux
possibilités
soit la mère a
raison et le père viole son
fils soit le père a raison et la mère
veut l'anéantir en tant que
père si la mère a
raison le placement est une mauvaise
solution si le père a raison le
placement est une mauvaise
solution ce n'est pas parce qu'une
décision
est
intermédiaire qu'elle est
bonne et permettez-moi de le dire
puisque je vais y venir aussi la
neutralité c'est ce que j'appelle une
bonne
planque je pour tout à fait vous dire
que la position neutre c'est la
mienne je vous donne des
chiffres j'ai une
expérience mon propos et je
l'espère
construit je peux décider que moi je
suis la position
neutre et que toute position qui
s'écarte de la mienne est une position
non neutre
militante
la neutralité c'est une bonne
planque lorsque vous êtes devant une
femme victime de violence conjugale
devant un enfant victime de violence
devant une personne victime de de de
vol si vous dites je suis neutre ça a
des conséquences si vous dites à un
enfant qui vous
dit après la séance d'éducation à la
sexualité après avoir vu la campagne de
sensibilisation sur les violences
sexuelles faites aux enfants si un
enfant vous
dit moi aussi c'est ce qui
m'arrive je veux pas retourner à la
maison soit vous dites je prends ta
parole au sérieux je te protège soit
vous dites je vais voir je vais
réfléchir c'est compliqué je dois rester
neutre mais c'est pas
neutre il n'y a pas de position neutre
alors c'est c'est l'une des raisons pour
les sans doute la
civise est peut-être
menacé parce qu'elle a ce que j'appelle
une
doctrine parce
que je pense si vous n'avez pas de
doctrine Mesdames et
Messieurs les
parlementaires
on pourrait vous faire voter n'importe
quoi
penser c'est avoir une appréhension de
la réalité et la CIV a une
doctrine et cette doctrine est si on ne
protège pas les enfants qui révèlent des
violences les conséquences sur la santé
sont
décuplé
si vous me donnez une heure de plus je
développe la vie du 21 septembre 2023
les conséquences sont visi direct
immédiate cette doctrine
est siil on n'organise pas un contrôle
social des agresseurs ils continueront à
violer des enfants tant qu'ils en auront
l'impunité et c'est pour cela qu'il faut
maintenir la CIV telle qu'elle est parce
qu'elle est dépositaire d'une
confiance qu'elle a une doctrine qu'en
écoutant les adultes
elle fait voir le visage des
enfant et que pour ma part je
souhaiterais non seulement que la cvie
soit maintenue mais qu'on me permett d'y
rester aussi pour y maintenir mon
engagement qui m'apporte beaucoup plus
de joie et d'édification que de
souffrance et tant qu'on ne fera pas des
séances d'éducation à la vie affective
et
sexuelle on ne changera rien
et chaque action de prévention est une
action de repérage et permettez-moi je
puis-je faire un petit clin d'œil aux
honorables parlementaires que vous êtes
à ce à cette heure de notre entretien
je puige madame la Présidente et
pardonnez-moi par avance mais pour je me
l'autorise au plus conservateur d'entre
vous je voudrais dire que l'école
publique a toujours été
conçu avec des missions
d'éducation d'instruction et
d'éducation mais si j'avais du temps je
parlerai des besoins fondamentaux de
l'enfant du besoin de
sécurité et je conclurai en disant que
les séances d'éducation à la vie
affective et sexuel doivent être
organisé dans le respect des besoins de
l'enfant et de son
développement on ne dit pas la même
chose à un enfant de 3 ans et à des
adolescents de 16 ans bien sûr c'est une
question de doctrine là
encore il faut non seulement les mettre
en œuvre et être sûr de ce qui se dit
or institutionnellement et politiquement
j'ai appris ça avec la civise nous
raisonnons toujours en terme de
dispositif et pas de
doctrine on fait des dispositifs on vote
des dispositifs on donne de l'argent à
des dispositifs on dit on a fait un
dispositif sans jamais pouvoir dire la
doctrine des
professionnels qui font vivre ce
dispositif ou qui
l'incarne
et si vous me disiez
que la vigueur avec laquelle je vous
expose ma doctrine est un signe de
loyauté et d'honnêteté j'en serai
honoré
pardon je vais donc
passer la parole à Colomb Brossel puis
marc Laménie Marie Mercier Olivia
Richard je demanderai d'être brève
et malheureusement je vous demanderai
également d'être bref dans vos réponses
non mais c'est simplement parce que je
sais que la séance reprend à 11h et donc
voilà il il n faut malheureusement parce
qu'on vous garderait bien toute la
journée il y a aucun problème nous avons
encore énormément de questions à vous
poser mais nous vous ferons revenir je
pense en tout cas nos collègues
comprennent pourquoi on vous fait venir
régulièrement
colombe merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur le Juge je
fais partie de ces sénateurs et
sénatrices qui vous ont lu qui vous ont
entendu mais qui vous entendent euh en
direct pour la première fois si je peux
dire ça ainsi
euh merci pour ce que vous dites même
s'il est euh un peu étrange de remercier
quelqu'un qui vous met un hercul dans le
ventre mais merci de venir le faire et
et et de le
porter si j'avais eu le moindre doute je
n'en avais pas en entrant dans la salle
je serais persuadé après vous avoir
écouté que l'action de la civise doit
continuer et que cette action est en
effet une
action de bien public voilà et que
finalement c'est peut-être ça que nous
construisons ensemble lorsque nous
sommes réunis
euh comme parlementaire c'est le bien
public euh vous décrivez un un système
en tout cas c'est comme ça que je l'ai
compris un
système la dimension systémique du dénis
est vraiment au cœur de ce que vous vous
décrivez et c'est vrai que ça donne
envie de de d'être au 20 novembre pour
voir quelles seront vos propositions
parce que c j'imagine à partir de ces
propositions que vous proposerez aux uns
et aux autres euh d'arriver à attaquer
la dimension systémique qui n'est pas
merci pour ces paroles c'est très
personnelle
mais ce ne sont pas des dispositifs les
uns à côté des autres et c'est bien
arrivé justement à à casser cette
dimension systémique et c'est
certainement à partir de de ces
propositions que nous pourrons les uns
les autres les unes les autres ici et
ailleurs voir comment accompagner
finalement les propositions que vous
porterez de façon
opérationnelle en tout cas je je je
crois que vous l'aurez compris nous nous
y sommes résolus euh donc on va attendre
le 20 novembre même si vous avez déjà
commencé à dévoiler quelques quelques
pistes de travail que ce soit sur le
droit de la famille la question du du
psychotrauma évidemment les questions
éducatives qui nous importent beaucoup
aux uns et aux autres j'avais deux
questions complémentaires en en
attendant le 20 novembre eu vous allez
présenter les les conclusions de
de vos travaux est-ce que vous envisagez
d'aller présenter les conclusions de ces
travaux également dans l'ensemble des
territoires comme vous avez organisé des
réunions de la CIVIS en en en terme
d'écoute de la parole euh je je crois
que si nous voulons si vous voulez je me
permet de dire nous faire en sorte que
ces ces préconisations ces propositions
elles soient portées par une communauté
d'Adult adulte bienveillant la plus
large possible il faut que cette parole
et ces propositions elles soi portées
mais je vous vois opiner du chef donc
j'imagine que la réponse est oui et puis
une question pardon si vous l'avez déjà
abordé chers collègues dans des travaux
précédents euh mais pour pouvoir pour ma
part avancer est-ce que vous identifiez
d'autres pays dans lesquels justement
cette question systémique du dénis
aurait été
euh
travailler de façon plus efficace que
celle que vous décrivez sur le constat
de la situation en
France merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente merci sincèrement monsieur le
juge monsieur le Président pour je
dirais vos l'engagement avec beaucoup de
cœur d'émotion partager parce que je
crois que là
aussi vous avez soulevé vraiment des des
problèmes de société qu'on ne
mesure qu'on ne mesure toujours pas
parce que malheureusement on est souvent
sans moyen et puis quand on en parle
localement sur nos départements
respectifs nos territoires métropole
outremè puisque je dirais au niveau de
du votre commission la civice vous avez
un une mission
aussi interministérielle puisque je dir
vous avez cité plusieurs ministères
éducation nationale justice ministère de
l'Intérieur
les les les préfecture sous-préfecture
mais aussi le lien avec les
collectivités territoriales alors nous
c'est vrai que
euh vous avez même mis des des des mots
forts avec beaucoup franchement de
d'émotions que nous vraiment sincèrement
partager vous remercions vraiment parce
que et anque parlait une question
question je me permet de poser comment
peut-on vous aider parce que je pense
que
là y a il y il y a le
travail de la prévention et c'est vrai
que on a examiné en commission des
finances c'était hier le budget de
l'Éducation nationale qui est quand même
le premier budget de l'État et on
s'aperçoit que je dirais on manque de
personnel de santé ou prévention ou
autre et et et c'est là qu'on voit que
bah beaucoup beaucoup reste à faire et
on ne sait pas comment faire et il y a
des associations il y a les auj dans
lesardenes on l' un peu de la CIDFF qui
F font des choses il y a des
associations mais comment comment aider
comment sensibiliser puis bah nos forces
de sécurité intérieure font ce qu'ils
peuvent et puis on manque
malheureusement de moyens humains il y a
le volet financier certes mais tout
repose sur les moyens humain et puis sur
les bons interlocuteurs alors voilà un
peu comment peut-on vous aider puis
merci
sincèrement Marie
Mercier merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Juge
merci que dire d'autres que dire
d'autres sans avoir juste envie de de de
pleurer de trembler quand j'ai commencé
mon travail sur les violences sexuelles
sur mineur je l'ai présenté à mon groupe
il y avait lor il y avait Marc on
m'avait donné 10 minutes ça en a duré
plus de 30 dans un silence très pesant
où enfin on mettait des mots durs sur
des gestes violents enfin on expliquait
et ensuite j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de
de confessions si je puis dire où des
monsieurs un peu vieux sont venus me
dire je comprends enfin ce qu'on m'a
fait c'était à mes collègues
ensuite j'ai j'ai pris mon bâton de
pèlerin j'ai fait le tour du département
toute les communautés de communes où je
suisis expliqué ce que c'était qu'une
violence
sexuelle il faut oser le dire
et là on est entendu j'ai expliqué
comment repérer un changement de
comportement chez un petit enfant
comment un enfant qui était victime
devenait un enfant hauteur forcément
est-ce que c'était que d'être une
victime et d'être gâché à vie parce que
un petit enfant c'est pas un petit
adulte c'est un adulte en construction
l'enfance doit être sanctuarisé l'école
doit être sanctuarisée l'enfant par
définition il n'a besoin que de
protection alors je racontais que dans
quand quand on couche nos petits-
enfants on leur raconte toujours une
histoire il était une fois parce que les
petits- enfants ont besoin de rêver mais
nous c'est il était une foi sans un S
celle de protéger les enfants alors je
n'ai que des pourquoi Monsieur le
pourquoi il faut tant d'énergie pour
sauver les plus vulnérables d'entre nous
pourquoi pourquoi depuis une loi a été
votée il y a 2 ans pourquoi on n'arrive
pas à protéger les enfants des films
pornographiques qui sont de plus en plus
violents la justice elle-même nomme un
médiateur on ne peut plus même plus
avoir confiance dans l'application de
cette loi nous prenons des dispositifs
ils ne sont pas évalués ils sont pas
jamais évalués alors ma réponse c'est
celle-ci c'est que quand on parle des
mineur dans l'imaginaire collectif ça
reste mineur que le respect n'existe pas
et que on n'avancera que quand on aura
fait des mineurs une cause
majeure tout est dit quand on a dit ça
alors ma seule question monsieur jus
c'est peut-être comment vous allez parce
que moi j'avais entre guillemets mi loin
dans mon cerveau toutes ces histoires
tout ce que j'avais lu tout ce que
j'avais écouté auprès des gendarmes
quand je leur disais vous surveiller des
sites pédo criminels toute la journée
mais comment vous faites et une gendarme
un jour m'a dit Madame si j'en sauve une
et ça m'avait donné du courage pour
aller aussi expliquer puis un moment je
et bien oui j'avais envie de renonc
parce que je me disais tu dépenses
tellement d'énergie et tu tu n'arrives à
rien donc on a besoin de vous on a
besoin que vous nous donniez aussi à
nous la force de dire tout ça de
continuer de le répandre vous nous direz
comment il faut faire pour que la civise
continue et sous quelle forme parce que
moi c'est ce qui me gêne aussi parce que
le ministère de la Santé qui est votre
qui est votre adresse comment ils
envisagent la suite et ma question
fondamentale monsieur le juge c'est
doit-on inscrire l'inceste dans la
Constitution
et Olivia
Richard pardon merci madame la
Présidente je fais partie de de ces
nouvelles éluses je suis bouleversée par
tous ces témoignages j'ai dû prendre en
note ce que vous disiez pour faire comme
un écran avec ce que vous vous décriviez
bon la fatigue est dans ça n pas je suis
sénatrice des Français établières de
France il y a des populations encore
plus éloigné que des autres mères car
évidemment lorsqu'on subit des violences
au sein d'une famille française à
l'étranger il y a des moyens de
coerction très simple comme prendre les
passeports et ça interdit c'est créer
une prison loin de tout et loin de de
tout système d'aide qui pourrait être
mise en place on ne parle pas des manque
de moyens dans les consulat ni du manque
de d'absence totale de formation du
personnel qui pourrait être un recours
chacun fait ce qu'il peut il y a des
systèmes associatifs et solidairire qui
se mettent en place mais bien sûr c'est
encore plus loin c'est encore plus
difficile mais j'ai été très frappé par
votre propos au début où vous expliquiez
qu'il n'y a pas de de prise en charge
adaptée dans les soins et j'imagine pas
davantage dans la réponse judiciaire et
comment on peut encore en être là
comment ça n'a pas
avancé excusez-moi de deux petites
minutes pour rajouter je dois partir en
séance donc je vais vous abandonner non
pas que ça ne
m'intéresse j'ai pris une très grosse
claque ce matin j'étais assistante
sociale dans un département pendant 33
ans je suis jeune sénatrice depuis
quelques semaines
euh je m'aperçois qu'on ne fait jamais
bien
qu'on est souvent à côté de la plaque
même quand on pense être dans ce qu'il y
a de mieux pour un enfant et moi j'en
reviens sur la formation
euh à tout niveaux alors je vais parler
des travailleurs sociaux forcément mais
de de tous ces gens qui gravitent autour
des des enfants on a parlé des
enseignants on peut parler des
animateurs on peut voilà il y a vraiment
tout un panel de personnes qui gravitent
autour des enfants et chacun doit mettre
sa pierre à l'édifice on en est tous
convaincus c'est sûr et et je voulais
quand même aussi préciser que même si
beaucoup de choses ne sont ne seront pas
réglées jamais réglées certainement ou
pas suffisamment il y a quand même
beaucoup de gens sur les terrains qui
s'investissent beaucoup d'associations
beaucoup beaucoup d'intervenants sociaux
ou non sociaux d'ailleurs mais et je
voulais aussi qu'on leur fasse un petit
clin d'œil c'est important et et je
reviens forcément sur l'information à
tout voilà
merci je dirais information et
formation monsieur le juge eu merci euh
mesames les sénatrices monsieurs le
sénateur de de vos propos et de et de
vos questions euh je répondrai très
rapidement euh merci si madame la
sénatrice est
juste bien sûr la formation la civise
j'en dirais dans un instant un peu plus
en détail la civise fidèle à l'idée
qu'il faut une doctrine a créé un outil
de formation de tous les professionnels
sur le repérage avec des des des repères
aussi concrets pratiques précis que
possible comment s'entretenir avec un
enfant ce qu'il faut dire ce qu'il ne
faut pas dire comment s'entretenir avec
un enfant en situation de handicap
[Musique]
cognitif comment avec vous voyez nous
l'avons construit avec des experts quels
sont les signes cliniques le tableau
clinique de l'enfant victime et ensuite
j'ai dit mais il faut un plan de
formation et on m'a dit mais il est déjà
diffusé on m'a même produit des chiffres
de diffusion antérieurs à la création de
l'outil moi j'ai dit non parce que je
veux une doctrine j'étais professeur à
l'École nationale de la magistrature je
peux vous dire qu'un Institut de
Formation vous ne prendrez jamais en
défaut faites-vous une formation sur
ceci sur cela tous vous diront oui la
preuve mais qu'est-ce qu'on dit c'est
une question de doctrine on raisonne en
affichage de dispositif pas de doctrine
je sais que c'est gênant de répéter
toujours la même chose mais je pense que
c'est le seul chemin et vous avez raison
il y a des professionnels et des
personnes
lumineuses partout tout et je ne veux
pas du tout laisser penser que rien
n'existe de positif vous savez nombreus
sont les victimes qui nous disent mais
oui la médecin cine raphaë l'écrit dans
le livre la démesure en parlant de la
CPE qu'attendu qu' l'a attendu un jour à
la sortie de l'école de la classe
elle dit à partir de cet instant je suis
devenu
indestructible
nos témoins nous le disent l'assistante
sociale l'avocat général à l'audience la
gentarme le policier quoi qu'il soit
arrivé même s'il a eu un acquitement
elle m'a
cru et c'est une lumière pour toujours
pour toute la vie le point fixe
simplement il faut honorer l'engagement
tous ces professionnels il faut les
soutenir et les
valoriser on peut créer des séances de
dépistage à l'école mais s'il y a pas de
médecin scolaire pas d'infirmière
scolaire pas d'assistante sociale
scolaire il y aura pas de séance de
dépistage et le fait de ne pas payer
pour avoir de la médecine scolaire coûte
10 milliards d'euros par
an ce n'est pas qu'une question de moyen
budgétaire mais c'est aussi une question
d'argent c'est d'abord une
question de
doctrine qui
est entre vos mains c'est ce que
j'appelle une législation plus
impérative vous faites confiance à mon
pouvoir souverain d'appréciation j'en
suis
heureux mais je crois parfois que vous
me faites trop
confiance un bon exemple de législation
impérative c'est la
loi sur les seuils d'âge pour les
violences
sexuelles juste justement appelé lois
billon je veux rendre hommage à Nick
billon à
nouveau il était déjà possible de dire
que quand un adulte
viole un enfant de 5 ans il y a pas
besoin de chercher s'il y a eu violence
contrainte menè surprise mais il a fallu
l'écrire dans la
loi il a fallu que porté par anque
billon vous votiez cette loi qui dit que
cette table est une table quand un
adulte commet un acte sexuel sur un
enfant mais ça s'appelle un viol il y a
pas besoin de demander à l'enfant si
l'enfant a dit oui ou a dit
non et il faut une législation
impérative parce que tant que vous
n'écrirez pas dans la loi que quand un
parent est déclaré coupable
d'inceste l'autorité parentale est
retiré automatiquement par les faet de
la
loi et bien les Pères inécieux
continuont de garder l'autorité
parentale al vous direz mais oui mais on
peut pas l'écrire parce que c'est
l'autorité parentale quand même c'est
important vous allez dire on peut pas
l'écrire parce que il y a peut-être des
cas où il faut pouvoir que apprécier
dans le dossier il y a des juges pour ça
oui c'est pour ça que je suis devenu
juge mais la loi doit être le point fixe
et quand 3 % des violeurs d'enfants sont
déclarés coupables
97 % ne le sont pas
pour les 3 % qui
restent c'est quand même que là on peut
dire qu'il a eu des éléments dans le
dossier que la doctrine s'est
matérialisé dans le dossier en quoi ce
serait contraire à un principe d'écrire
dans le Code civil que la déclaration
pénale de culpabilité a une conséquence
civile le retrait de l'autorité
parentale mais en quoi ce serait
contraire à un
principe
voilà ce qu'il faut écrire dans la
Constitution aucun principe n'est
contraire à la
raison le retrait de l'autorité
parentale n'est pas une
peine c'est la conséquence
civile d'une décision
pénale prononcée souverainement par une
juridiction indépendante et impartiale
au terme d'un procès contradictoire
vous voyez pourquoi je parlais des
bonnes planques et des
principes avançons ou n'avançons
pas mais il faut choisir qui on
protège c'est la loi donc l'argent le
budget mais d'abord la loi et entre les
deux dans l'ordre des priorités et bien
oui le le cette doctrine il faut la la
la la donner aux professionnels les
outillers parce qu'on leur envoie aussi
des injonctions paradoxales
ah ben les institutrices ou les les les
assistantes sociales les auxiliaires de
puculture elles doivent
signaler et
après après elles n'ont plus
d'information
elles sont tous les jours confrontées
aux personnes qui viennent chercher
l'enfant
elles savent pas on leur dit mais non
mais on peut rien vous dire on peut rien
vous dire parce qu'on a pas le temps de
vous le dire parce que vous pouvez pas
savoir on les met en danger
ou alors comme au médecin on dit mais
vous devez signaler mais ah peut-être
que vous irez devant la commission
disciplinaire mais sauf que ces
professionnels ils ont une vie ils ont
des
enfants ils peuvent pas être au chômage
et ils se demandent pourquoi la
sourciété leur leur demande une chose et
son
contraire nous nous avons on créer un
outil de
formation que la cise veut être fidèle à
son
engagement les comparaison
internationale oui en Allemagne il y a
une
commission il y a eu des travaux en
Angleterre démarche des églises a
conduit beaucoup d'États à s'inscrire
dans une démarche
similaire vous dire qu'il y a un pays
qui a
une législation
qui peut être copiée collée non la
réalité est la même
partout le déis est le même dans tous
les pays les chiffres sont les mêmes et
selon les pays il y a des
législations qui peuvent
[Musique]
être
instructive inspirante sur tel ou tel
point
notamment pour les soins
spécialisés les soins spécialisés des
troubles de stress
post-traumatique
existent ils ne sont pas
dispensés c'est exactement comme si je
vous
disais le soin d'une
fracture
du coude
existe du pied et ils ne sont pas
dispensés on soigne autre chose
ou pas et ça coûte de l'argent pour les
personnes moi y a des parents qui
disent je ne peux plus payer les séances
de soins spécialisés pour mon
enfant il y a des adultes qui
disent mais moi ça me fait énormément de
bien les soins
spécialisés le mdr par exemple mais
d'autres
je ça me fait beaucoup de bien mais j'ai
une famille j'ai mes enfants j'ai mon
mari tout le budget de la maison peut
pas être pris pour moi donc
j'arrête moi je trouve quey vous parliez
[Musique]
d'émotion demander demandz si j'allais
bien je vous le dis je vais très bien
mais
ça ça me je trouve que c'est une
injustice dans
l'injustice
consciente alors nous avons modéliser un
parcours de soins spécialisé du
psychotraumatisme
parce que la civilise a une doctrine et
que je sais comme ce que c'est que faire
une politique
publique si nous n'avions pas modélisé
un parcours de soins
spécialisé et bien ça n'aurait pas
enclenché le passage à la construction
d'une politique publique nous avons dit
25 à 30 séances
renouvelabl séance d'évaluation TR à peu
près séance de
stabilisation 10
15 séance centrée sur le trauma
autant et
Séan
de reposement de stabilisation à nouveau
issu de l'expérience issu de la pratique
de pays étranger comme les barnaus en
Islande il faut le
faire
alors la présentation de la CIV dans les
territoires moi je je je vais très bien
et vous savez vous le savez évidemment
quand on travaille avec des
enfants mais on est dans la vie et moi
je je le dis toujours les enfants sont
des gens
sérieux qui vivent leur vie
sérieusement et quand on prend les
enfants au sérieux on
grandit donc je grandis
être juge des enfants c'est dur mais
c'est
extraordinaire je moi je quand je vais
pas bien je pense au visage d'enfant et
je pense au fois où j'ai croisé dans la
rue des enfants qui sont devenus des
jeunes qui me disent monsieur le Ju vous
vous
souvenez et donc j'espère que dans
quelques mois je serai toujours à la
civise je vous dis les choses clairement
et pour tout vous dire je vous dis les
choses aussi clairement que ça je j'ai
du mal à comprendre que la civise ne
soit pas maintenue pour être tout à fait
honnête je ne comprends pas ce qui se
passe je ne vois pas le problème ça me
paraît tellement une
évidence la civise répond à une
mission nouvelle elle répond à un besoin
auquel il n'était pas répondu jusqu'à
présent elle ne prend la place de
personne elle ne coûte pas
cher où serait le
problème la
doctrine
la manière de dire la
doctrine l'espace que ça
occupe moi je n'ai pas demandé on m'a
appelé et je souhaite pouvoir continuer
personne n'est irremplaçable évidemment
personne personne personne
mais je
pourquoi je veis bien
c'est un engagement il y a encore du
travail à faire et des idées j'en ai
beaucoup y compris le lien avec les
territoires oui évidemment c'est très
important structurer ça dans les
territoires et nous avons commencé bien
sûr il faut continuer nous c'est une des
propositions que j'ai fait
institutionnellement pour continuer à
aller rechercher les bonnes pratiques
les mettre en
valeur et puis avoir ce réseau mais moi
oui je je je veux aller à
Mayotte je veux aller on dit alors vous
n'avez pas suffisamment parlé des
outr-mères je dis ce n'est pas vrai et
les
outremères c'est une réalité qui est
hétérogène aussi
entre la Réunion Saint-Pierre et mlon
euh la Guadeloupe ben il y a les mêmes
différences qu'entre la Réunion et et
l'au où je suis né qu'entre Nantes et et
Toulouse enfin je est-ce que je peux
dire ça est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
vous voyez mais bien sûr ça va prendre
du temps il faudra que on puisse aller
dans tous les outr mè et dans toutes les
villes où nous ne sommes pas
allés alors sous quel comment nous
aidez
vous allez
trouver moi écoutez
je vous savez les VI la
prescription la prescription des
fondements de la prescription c'est
sanctionner la carence du
plignant des
fondement philosophi et juridi de la
prescription
c'est sanctionner la faute du plignant
qui a attendu trop longtemps
et les victimes n disent mais moi je
suis allé au commissariat je l'ai vu
comme comme une porte qui m ferm au
ne fermer la CIV ce sera exactement
comme la prescription ce sera dire
écoutez vous avez eu 3 ans vous n'avez
pas témoigné tant pis pour
vous une promesse dure 3 ans et
deuxièm j'espère pouvoir continuer à à
vous dire à ma manière
que il est possible de
d'avancer donc vous pouvez l'écrire vous
pouvez le voter
aussi en attendant que la loi soit votée
il faut que la CIV soit maintenue tel qu
c'est une institution originale inédite
autonome un peu souple on nous dit
parfois c'est au Parlement d'évaluer les
politiques publiques évidemment
et je ne voudrais pas que la
CIV avale
le Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale ce
serait être très gourmand etelle la fort
à faire mais à sa place comme ce
matin participer à l'œuvre commune c'est
tout ce que nous
voulons et bien sur ce mot il me reste à
conclure
en je je il me semble que une des
raisons de la poursuite de la civise en
tout cas une des raisons pour lesquelles
moi je je propose effectivement que nous
soutenions ce maintien c'est que on le
sait entre définir une politique
publique et l'appliquer la piloter parce
qu'en fait on souffre souvent de manque
de pilotage dans des politiques qui
touchent énormément de sujets puisqu'on
l'a dit aussi bien l'éducation nationale
que la justice
que les les for de sécurité intérieure
c'est réellement de l'interministériel
or chacun y compris au sein d'un
ministère fonctionne en silo quand on
voit sur les violences intrafamiliales
il y en a un qui s'occupe despules rien
que sur le ministère de la Justice un
qui va s'occuper despau un qui va
s'occuper de la victime un qui va
s'occuper des auteurs et plus et
personne ne parle les uns avec les
autres donc globalement il y a zéro
pilotage même au sein d'un seul
ministère or on a besoin réellement de
politique piloté de de façon
interministérielle et si on n'a pas une
structure à côté qui est là pour le
rappeler pour aiguillonner pour relancer
pour insister et bien on sent que ça
part et sans parler du fait que nous
changeons régulièrement de ministre et
donc il n'y a pas forcément de
continuité dans une politique et dans la
façon dont s'est mené en fonction des
ministres qui peuvent changer donc si on
n pas ces organismes parallèle si on n
pas le Parlement qui a effectivement une
durée de vie plus longue que celle d'un
ministre pour pouvoir rappeler et
notamment le Sénat qui ne se renouvelle
que par moitié donc on est sûr d'avoir
effectivement cette continuité je pense
qu'on n arrivera pas et donc nous avons
besoin sur ces sujets-là que vous
puissiez continuer à le faire nous
allons comme nous devons conclure là
nous allons vous proposer un courrier
euh sur lequel nous nous sommes euh mise
d'accord on va vous le proposer et
ensuite sur la base de ce que vous nous
aurez éventuellement proposé comme
modification je l'enverrai à chacun et
chacune d'entre nous pour que vous
fassiez également vos remarques et afin
que nous puissions l'envoyer au
président de la République signé de nous
toutes et nous tous Voilà euh donc bah
mes chers
collègues il me reste à vous remercier
d'être resté
jusqu'au bout je pense que cette
audition le méritait amplement mais
merci beaucoup et vraiment merci de tout
le travail que vous faites et soyez
assurés de du soutien de l'intégralité
de nos
membres merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames les sénatrices monsieur le
sénateur et votre soutien si si clair et
réel
engagé nous
vraiment